Looking at this graphically, we might see
packets generated at a particular rate and the
packets might be received at slightly different
times, depending on network delay. These types of
delays are the types that we want to avoid when we playout, so if we
wait to receive several packets. And fill the
buffer before we start playing, say to here.
Then, we can have a playout schedule
that is smooth, regardless of the erratic arrival
times that may result from network delays. So
this playout delay or buffering allows the client
to achieve a smooth playout. Some delay
at the beginning of the playout is acceptable.
Startup delays of a few seconds are things
that users can typically tolerate, but clients cannot
tolerate high variation in packet arrivals if the buffer starves or if there
aren't enough packets in the buffer. Similarly, small amount of loss or missing
data does not disrupt the playback but retransmitting a lost packet, might
actually take too long and result in delays or starvation of the playout buffer.